welcome to this video playing smita wait
s'matter 08 from the US let's see can I
do something else maybe the color play
this for a while hmm yeah with be three
RC 3 mp3 is a bit more interesting but I
really don't know that the setup is okay
for what it's nothing I'm spectacularly
great but you can't play that with you
for coming let's see how is playing it
with 36 I could play you for here from
I'm you p yeah maybe go for that i QP no
it's not taking for some reason I'm
threatening me five buddy we had yeah
maybe he's considering to take on d4
first
yep that seems to be the case night
before hmm I have to check on b5
probably he's taking quite some time
interesting more difficult can I take on
age 7 it seems he it seems he fears that
mmm ok a move like d5 I don't really
know I cannot really keep the king and
the center ok let's continue to develop
here this was the main idea of rook up
there should be three quickly quickly
castle quickly getting the rookie aside
i have but should be one if necessary
but I wonder about Queen d2 I Scott f5
okay Scott f5 hmm probably ok maybe one
more preparation the tongue cruelly
pepper sugar ok I want to get this out
of it I would have five with tempo and
maybe just Queen d3 this typical
attacking idea can be good yeah the
moment I'm threatening that I think he
may I probably needs to move the Queen
away I do this now Queen d3 duricef five
really
nothing greater okay maybe here so that
I have Bishop a 223 f5 Bishop a chew to
attack the in this case Oh week pawn on
d6 yeah he's got that move I just saw
this as well I don't want to take really
mmm yeah he maybe takes and then it's
really very little that I have okay I'm
flicking this in but it's not a big deal
for him to to fight that maybe still
Bishop the shrimp a tune okay this is
nothing special for what its it's not
bad or anything but don't have anything
great I've got 95 menu maybe 95 can be
can be helpful hmm I can take here and
take only six now
I really don't look is six see if i take
here rookie six it's Roxy to know that's
not even a threat ready not weird okay
I'm going to I'm going to grab him
that's also g6 hang so we are talking
about a double attack him d 6 and d5 and
the night cannot move rook c2 I can take
one of the pieces the the design is
protesting yeah just a piece right
cannot he cannot cover it yeah Queen B 5
was just the lemon yeah I don't know
this this looks rather okay I mean
somehow this Queen c7 bishop d6 set up
does not fit much into into the
structure but ok it's nothing nothing
special some alternatives here and they
are 95 for example but ok all pretty
normal if you consider it's a blitz
named 97 Black is certainly ok Queen d3
and now yeah I don't know what f5 is not
really necessary anymore now with the
night here maybe you can just go here
that's not a bad move actually blocking
this and maybe if this battery is not in
effect anymore something that night f4
as possible yeah this is probably around
equal ok right here I have this this
display against the weakness 95 Jim ok
here still nothing nothing great i mean
computer once played Bishop c4 here
probably preventing preventing any
Bishop b5 and stuff ok and here it seems
that Queen B 6 is ok for black yeah well
as long as he keeps c6 undergone a cover
I keep keeps it covered I really don't
see what what great great stuff is
possible here okay this is just okay for
for both sides I've got this slide
weakness here and he's got a slight
weakness only 60 it probably cancelled
each other out yeah this is just this is
just blundering like that and now two
pieces hanging and yeah no way to to
defend it this is simply nothing nothing
happening everything's everything is
protected ok but sudden end of this game
thanks for watching